habt ihr euch schon mal gefragt was es
alles braucht um ein neues medikament zu
erfinden so eine kleine weiße tablette
sieht vielleicht nicht kompliziert aus
aber was es brauchte um sie zu
entwickeln ist mega kompliziert
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
forschen monate wenn nicht sogar jahre
nach dem perfekten kombinationen
verbindungen und studi rungen von
inhaltsstoffen und den allergrößten teil
der kandidaten bekommen wir dabei
niemals zu gesicht weil sie nicht
funktionieren
moderne medikamente sind high tech
produkte das macht sie teuer weniger
zugänglich und sorgt auch dafür dass für
seltene krankheiten erst gar nicht nach
medikamenten geforscht wird
das alles könnte sich jetzt ändern denn
im moment findet ein umdenken in der
forschung statt wie künstliche
intelligenz den prozess der
arzneimittelentwicklung gerade
revolutioniert und was das mit lego zu
tun hat das erkläre ich euch jetzt
wie macht man eigentlich ein neues
medikament stellen wir uns mal vor der
wirkstoff dhe nicht herstellen möchte
wäre ein lego haus die bausteine sind
einzelne atome und größere strukturen
wie zum beispiel die wände oder das dach
stellen atom gruppen oder sogar kleinere
moleküle da so ein haus zu bauen ist
aber gar nicht so einfachen deswegen
schauen wir uns an aus welchen
bausteinen unser haus zusammengesetzt
ist und versuchen dabei strukturen zu
finden die wir schon aus anderen lego 6
kennen
glücklicherweise gibt es auf dem markt
schon ganz viele lego häuser ich muss
das dach meines hauses zum beispiel
nicht neu erfinden weil ich das auch
nach der anleitung eines anderen lego
sets bauen kann
so oder so ähnlich geht man auch in der
chemie vor natürlich bauen die dann
nicht mit lego sondern die machen etwas
das nennt sich retro synthese dieser
ganze prozess des aufteilen der
gesamtstruktur in kleinere bekannte
bausteine das ist retro synthese und das
ist für wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler eine enorm wichtige
hilfestellung denn sonst müsste man
immer wieder komplett bei null anfangen
in der regel hört die retro synthese
dann auf wenn ich einen baustein für ein
medikament kaufen kann um zum beispiel
aspirin herzustellen braucht man unter
anderem benzol
anstatt jetzt aber auch noch benzol in
seine einzelteile zu zerlegen kann ich
es auch einfach kaufen wenn es die
fertigen bausteinen aber nicht zu kaufen
gäbe dann müsste ich theoretisch so
lange weiter mein geplantes haus retro
synthetisch und bausteine zerteilen
wer sich bei einzelnen legosteinen also
den atomen angekommen wäre
in der praxis sieht das dann so aus ich
stelle mir mein traumhaus vor also
meinen traum wirkstoff und zerlege
diesen gedanklichen bausteine die ich
dafür brauche ein passendes fundament
nämlich zb aus der anleitung für einen
lego bauernhof aber was ist schon ein
haus ohne wände also nehme ich diese
wende hier die passende über auf mein
fundament super ganz entscheidend für
mein haus ist aber dieses spezielle dach
und das brauche ich unbedingt das kann
ich mir praktischerweise von einem
anderen lego set ausleihen aber wie ihr
seht passt das nicht so wirklich auf
meine wende ich brauche also wende die
zu meinem dach passen
okay von vorne jetzt muss ich mir weiter
ganz viele liege häuser anschauen bis
sich ein passendes fundament und
kompatible wende für meinen dach
gefunden habe und das kann ganz schön
lange dauern
und genau so machen dass auch
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
wenn sie ein neues medikament erfinden
wollen nun natürlich dass ein haus viel
einfacher ist mit fundamenten wänden und
dächern als ein medikament das hat viel
mehr variablen und die anleitungen für
bereits bekannte bausteine sind auch
nicht mal eben so bei lego zu finden
sondern verstecken sich zwischen
millionen publikationen aus den letzten
200 jahren und hier darf man nicht
vergessen dass im labor auch nicht
einfach drauflos gebaut wird beim einem
lego haus würde ich eigentlich erst mit
dem zusammenbau und anfang wenn ich auf
dem papier vorgezeichnet habe welche
baustelle ich genau brauche und theorie
versus praxis ist natürlich eine
komplizierte sache
deswegen muss für ein medikament die
reaktion im labor nachgebildet und
getestet werden
in diesem ganzen prozess von planung
entwicklung und tests passiert immer
wieder eins es wird gescheitert
das führt dazu dass die entwicklung
eines arzneimittels jahrzehnte lang
dauern kann
aber was wäre wenn dieser mühselige
prozess automatisiert werden könnte
[Applaus]
klar auch mit ki müssen trotzdem noch
die richtigen bausteine miteinander
kombiniert werden
der entscheidende punkt ist aber dass so
eine ki die fehlerquelle und bremse
nummer eins ersetzen soll nämlich den
menschen selbst die fähigste
wissenschaftlerin der welt die nicht
schlafen muss und 24 stunden am tag
kombination und ausprobiert macht fehler
und muss im schlimmsten fall von vorne
anfangen eine ki wird mit allen
bekannten bauplänen aus 200 jahren
forschung gefüttert und weiß genau
welche chemischen reaktionen unter
welchen bedingungen am besten
funktionieren die kennt also die besten
baupläne wodurch fehler gar nicht oder
zumindest seltener passieren
ein mensch hat das im studium vielleicht
auch alles mal gelernt aber erinnert
sich bestimmt nicht immer daran und ist
vor allem nicht unabhängig also nicht
falsch verstehen die geht es nicht um
lobbyismus oder bezahlte studien
es gibt auch mit ki vielmehr geht es
darum dass sich nach dutzenden jahren
wissenschaftlicher praxis vielleicht
lieblinge eingeschlichen haben so nach
dem motto never change a winning team
eine karte auf der anderen seite geht
aus einem neutralen blickwinkel an das
thema ran
welche stoffe funktionieren miteinander
beim menschen laufen wir gefahr dass die
frage ist von welchen stoffen weiß ich
dass sie miteinander funktionieren
das ist ein kleiner unterschied mit
großen auswirkungen ok eine ki findet
also theoretisch schnellere effizientere
und vor allem unkonventionellere
reaktionen
aber ganz ohne menschliche hilfe geht es
dann natürlich doch nicht eine k ist er
eine praktische hilfestellung die die
fleißarbeit übernehmen kann und das
krasse an der sache ist das ist keine
idee die irgendjemand irgendwann mal
hatte oder eine zukunftsvision
das alles passiert jetzt gerade die
ersten karten alle mittel sind schon auf
dem weg
aber was bedeutet das für uns erstens
weniger fehler bedeuten auch dass es
theoretisch weniger zeit braucht um ein
arzneimittel zu entwickeln
normalerweise dauert das jahre teilweise
jahrzehnte das letzte jahr hat aber
glaube ich ziemlich deutlich gezeigt
dass es verdammt nützlich sein kann
schnell ein medikament parat zu haben
wenn wir gerade von einer krankheit
überrumpelt werden
zweitens bedeutet weniger zeit oft auch
weniger kosten im schnitt kostet das
aktuell 2,6 milliarden euro um ein neues
arzneimittel zu entwickeln
diese kosten müssen und verkauft
natürlich wieder reingeholt werden plus
marge für einen pharmakonzern lohnt sich
super teure forschung leider nicht wenn
es nicht viele abnehmer geben wird
wenn aber die entwicklung drastisch
günstiger wird dann kann es sich für
unternehmen in zukunft vielleicht auch
lohnen arzneimittel gegen zum beispiel
die chargers krankheit zu entwickeln
die plattform allem entwicklungsländer
und bisher wird der leider viel zu wenig
zu geforscht also lassen wir das mal
zusammen
eine könnte für innovative schnellere
und günstigere arzneimittel sorgen
obendrein soll die entwicklung so aber
auch noch zugänglicher gemacht werden
eine studie aus 2018 hat acht reaktionen
in einer retro synthese software auf die
probe gestellt und jetzt kommt der
hammer
die reaktionen waren nicht nur ein
voller erfolg und haben ein
existierendes patent verbessert sondern
sie konnten von unerfahrenen studenten
hergestellt werden und das mit der
gleichen qualität
das bedeutet dass die ki in diesem fall
vertrauenswürdige ergebnisse produziert
hat die sich auch noch an
unterschiedliche anforderungen anpassen
können ziemlich cool
okay aber das hört sich ja auch so an
als ob das eigentlich nur für große
unternehmen interessant ist und klar
irgendwann profitieren wir auch davon in
dem medikamente besser und günstiger
werden
aber solche tools bleiben ja bestimmt
nur den big playern überlassen oder
tatsächlich falsch gedacht ihr könnt ihr
jetzt schon bei software benutzen die
euch bei der retro synthese unterstützt
ihr könntet theoretisch ein neues
medikament erfinden für die
chemikerinnen und chemiker unter euch
gibt es kostenlose sind software wie zum
beispiel star ja hier könnt ihr einfach
den struktur code der chemischen
verbindung eingeben also die abfolge von
atomen wie sie molekül auftritt und die
ki findet für euch automatisch die
synthese routen von den ausgangsstoffen
hin zum gewünschten molekül die profis
benutzen natürlich keine freeware hier
wird mit silvia eis hin und cia
gearbeitet alles richtig gute
zungenbrecher letzteres wurde übrigens
entwickelt vom wissenschafts und
technologie unternehmen merkt die uns
bei diesem video hier unterstützen und
keine sorge auf die bisherigen inhalte
dieses videos hatte unser sponsor wie
immer keinen einfluss das ist alles in
unabhängiger recherche entstanden die
entwicklung von xynthia hat stolze 15
jahren gedauert und in der jetzigen form
kennt die ki hunderttausend reaktions
regeln die alle per hand 1 kodiert
wurden
forscherinnen und forscher geben einfach
das gewünschte molekül ein und können
sogar filtern welche materialien und
kosten sind wir ja einplanen sollen
dieser ganze prozess geht so schnell
dass man noch am selben tag mit der
synthese beginnen kann so eine these ist
quasi das gegenteil der retro synthese
es ist das zusammenführen von bausteinen
zu einem molekül es ging natürlich auf
dem papier alles super spannend ist aber
nicht nur theorie wohin die reise geht
das kann man anhand von sind wir jetzt
schon gut erkennen
denn es sind ja hat tatsächlich baupläne
für 15 potenzielle cupid 19 arzneimittel
gefunden
dadurch dass du eine ki direkt
verschiedene lego baupläne für ein
arzneimittel anlegt können unternehmen
das rezept an ihre produktion anpassen
man kann sich aus mehreren bauplänen den
aussuchen der sich am einfachsten
produzieren lässt und so knappheit oder
engpässe verhindern oder sogar
produktionen überall auf der welt
ermöglichen muss vorher nicht möglich
war
und das ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht
alles was solche programme mal leisten
werden sind wir ja wird zum beispiel
regelmäßig geupdatet was wir jetzt
gerade sehen ist wahrscheinlich nur der
anfang von dem was ki in der
arzneimittelentwicklung mal verändern
wird
wenn jetzt noch mehr über xynthia
erfahren wollt dann verlinke ich euch
unten in der video beschreibung mal eine
website auf den noch mal ganz viele
weiterführende infos und material zu dem
projekt findet was dann sind wir und
anderen k s zur arzneimittelentwicklung
auch super interessant ist kunden wird
immer wichtiger und kann vielleicht bald
schon ein entscheidender skill für
chemikerinnen und chemiker werden wir
sehen das auch schon in anderen
bereichen die vorher eigentlich gar
nichts mit programmieren zu tun hatten
autohersteller setzen sich seit einigen
jahren auch mit machine learning
auseinander und mittlerweile müssen
journalisten mit data science methoden
arbeiten um große datenmengen
auszuwerten
über künstliche intelligenz und
maschinen learning haben wir hier auf
dem kanal schon eine ganze video reihe
gemacht die wir bald auch noch erweitern
werden
die könnt euch hier anschauen ansonsten
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
und die glocke zu aktivieren denn sonst
könnte die ein neues video verpassen
und wie immer viereck fürs zuschauern
und bis zum nächsten mal bleibt
neugierig patrick
hereinspaziert